[Music]
this lady played a deadly game of
hide-and-seek with her boyfriend died
because she didn't go and see what died
and see wait is he that dedicated what
he's really dedicated to the game I know
what happened they played on a volcano
no they played in the ocean no they
played in an S&M dungeon they were in
Florida so close to the ocean but no so
what happened here is this woman she has
been charged with second degree murder
after she meditated her boyfriend to die
in a suitcase which she claims was a
game of hide and go
hide-and-go-seek gone wrong but how did
he get himself in there right cuz those
new away things are kind of small yeah
well like he's zipping the suitcase like
did maybe she uh yeah right so the
reason why she got charged for this [ __ ]
because they found video evidence that
proved she knew what the [ __ ] she was
doing and that he was screaming for help
and saying that he couldn't breathe and
she was like yeah that's a evil
girlfriend did is did his Alexa give him
good give him away Alexa did his like
Amazon own [ __ ] song she was
recording this [ __ ] so when police she
was she trying to get away with it she
said she put her boyfriend in a suitcase
went upstairs passed out on her bed woke
up the next morning about 11:00 a.m. and
when she went downstairs to go look for
him that's when she realized oh [ __ ] I
didn't get my boyfriend out of the
suitcase supposedly so BAM it's the
stupidest lie ever do right so forget to
be my boyfriend on citycam we were
playing hide-and-seek and then I helped
them get into the hut and I would have
been like first off you're lying because
that's not how you play hide and seek
sadly he's supposed to [ __ ] hide
without you knowing you might help him
[ __ ] not supposed to know where your
boyfriend's hiding I see John say she
looks like she was like drunk or
something did the hide-and-seek
committee come out and condemn this yeah
cuz I be I believe your honor does it
make sense that Exhibit A she [ __ ]
helped the guy hide she's the one that's
it
and if I'm her defense attorney of my
late gentlemen he never played game of
hide-and-seek we need something where
somebody was never never Irish in okay
right and she's supposed to be counting
down from 60 what's she doing hopping
the guy hide yeah that'll make sense why
is she coming sixty one thousand so then
that when first responders found the
boyfriend
he had a small laceration on his lip
what happened
he's bird-dogging Jian Jilin yeah yeah
oh he's intimidating Jean oh so that her
comment is gonna be bred dog yeah never
heard it I've explained it before on the
show it's my exercise appointment here
that the guy was found with a small
laceration on his Alyssa is distracting
what's happening right I'm bird dogging
her and what appeared to be some
bruising around his eye when he was
found punched them and said go in the
suitcase yeah little [ __ ] but we do
know because the recording that he was
fighting okay now I'm gonna tell you
what the recording so then that's when
do we have the don't have I don't want
to hear tell you I don't have it I'd
like to tell you what happened in the
videos so they're saying that there were
two videos found on her phone so at
11:12 p.m. on that Sunday night
he began yelling her name well she was I
got to pick a show while he was trapped
in the suitcase oh my god I cried he
can't breathe but then that's when she
said for everything you've done to me
[ __ ] you laughing in the video and then
he called for her again and then she
said or he said I can't [ __ ] breathe
seriously and then she said yeah that's
what you do when you choke me oh then he
kept telling her that he couldn't
breathe and that's when she would
respond that's on you oh that's what I
feel like when you cheat on me why she's
saying you probably you you should
probably shut the [ __ ] up what if he's
been choking and beating her and
cheating on her does this man deserves
to die legally but then how did she get
him to be in a suitcase out of all
places I don't how do you convince a
[ __ ] to go in a suitcase I think
maybe they probably were intoxicated I'm
just totally my assumption they probably
were in telling apart oh we're Tech
funny games yeah
fun and games and then that's when he
was like oh [ __ ] I really can't breathe
and that's what she was like as small as
this man that he can fit in a suitcase
is now man I saw a little league team or
some [ __ ] carrying suitcases bigger than
their dads yeah they're [ __ ] gigantic
you were carrying that yeah their time
there's air tight suitcases yes
that's crazy they can't breathe maybe
he's close father he's lying
maybe he could breathe but he's just
trying to get out so he died Lyons the
girlfriend oh I'm okay I'm okay
I guess I killed my boyfriend looks
boyfriend she's a woman friend yeah oh
damn looks kind of crazy Matt Barnes his
eyes don't match yeah his eyes but he's
alive right no he's dead shot of him
then I don't know yeah true why does it
look who's taking the same spot as the
girl it does look like that maybe it was
a prior fight maybe they had a turbulent
relationship and it was very toxic he
shouldn't have never gotten that
suitcase done yeah yeah me too
maybe it was one of those jokes where it
was like hey I'm going overseas and he's
like will you take me in your suitcase
and she's like yeah I was trying let's
put all those yoga lessons to work to
work yeah and he's like watch this yeah
Oh hit the downward dog in there yeah
they're chopping dropping yes that Davin
yes because it is pretty fun to be in a
suitcase though have you ever been put
in a bag we're a kid no oh I put Isaac
in a duffle bag that was pretty fun oh I
put him in a bag - well his head was
sticking up yeah when he was a baby I
had him like gonna you know bag thingy
not when he was like six I put them in a
big tripod bag or something and then
also in a box box in his car and he
popped out that's cute
yeah it's fun putting people when they
want to be they want to well it's way
more fun my favorite thing to do now as
a kid was with my cousins we used to
roll each other up in blankets like
burritos like really really really
that's fun though it's fun and we'd
break out of it you know are you
claustrophobic
yeah just thinking of all this [ __ ] I'm
just like I can't even lay on her
really for watching if we're watching
like a movie if I have too much of me is
honor and if I blankets already I'm just
like what do you think that came from my
dad
well her trauma yeah but we were playing
wasn't anything bad like we were just
playing and he would just pretend dead
and then I'd be like I got breathe but I
think I was probably already born with
it do you have to kick the sheets out at
the hotel when they get in yes because
it does feel too tight but it's not a
closer probably thing I like I don't
like that my feet feel like this I
always untuck you you keep it tucked I
feel like it's a sleeping bag oh so I go
in and it's like a condom if the bottoms
the bottom is so likely yeah you have
little tiny feet so usually like this or
little feet maybe doesn't bother you I
sleep on my stomach I mean I do but
that's not my son you guys see that meme
where it's like Saget it's like like
like this on the bed and it's like the
perfect sleeping deal sleeping position
yeah yeah we probably have one foot down
like it was it was sagging from Street
Fighter it was like the idea oh yeah
yeah one of these up and yours counts
like this oh yeah I like sleeping like
that yeah do you guys think when your
stomach is bad I think I'd sleep more
like dhalsim dhalsim arms stretched i
like snug things though especially
vagina I knew it your layer head on the
couch
no he's big and I started buying all
constructed these are these lip stickers
have you guys seen them yeah I you I we
for snoring okay cuz I used to like wake
up random in the middle of the night
throat's hella dry so have to drink
water and it kind of interrupts my sleep
so I bought this like stick with me and
it sticks roofs together what forces you
to breathe out of your nose
see you man like I can't read really did
you get that a little hole yeah I did
that to my snoring how scary do you look
in the morning [ __ ] scared and now I
try to kiss him and I'm like oh I have
the deepest sleep now why if you have
sleep apnea it [ __ ] up your sleep I
think I had made me - leave Evan but
then when you do that you did it you
know what I used to do I used to have
the mouthpiece for snoring oh and I
covered it with the sticker the nose
thing I can't breathe y'all had some
deep sleep though I'm gonna try that
tonight I haven't done that in a minute
dude me too because for me I can't put
it normally yeah sticker it like this
way I have to do it at an angle because
in the morning I wake up and my mouth is
still open like somehow my jaw is still
it's got strong and yeah so I have to do
it sideways in order for my lips to
close its really tough really knock out
see no - all sticky that went I kept at
3 a.m. I try to y'all not to take it off
for like go back to your room no bite -
that's why I'm so shocked that doing it
this way doesn't work I have to go so
you're gonna sleep with stickers on your
mouth yeah my nose yeah you know I just
started with a breathing machine that
the old people have but I want one does
sleep apnea one yeah ok so apparently if
I could sleep [ __ ] good I won't man I
don't give a [ __ ] what I look like she's
gonna conquer the day if you feel okay
apparently I snore I didn't know that
until I got married but like I I and
normally I either sleep on my side or on
my back and when I sleep on my back I'm
so like okay so I sleep under like
sometimes I'll have like the pillow over
my face and I just knocked the [ __ ] out
right but when I sleep on my back I
snore a lot so like what I've been doing
lately is I'll wake up in the middle of
the night because I feel like I'm
snoring I don't want to wait she up so
I'll like make sure to roll over and
[ __ ] sleep and like cuddle a pillow
and [ __ ] but I've been trying to find
ways to alleviate my snoring sleep a
strip on my mouth is what I was shelling
it up maybe that's not the reason why I
use it I got it on Amazon
me too and you can sleep like that
comfortably there's no no strip thing
yeah opens up your nostrils and you're
like I could breathe so well so you
cover your mouth and you have a strip on
your nose
the deepest breaths in the deepest sleep
recently and then you and you as a
result he's not sewing you sleep nice we
also get in the middle of a night either
yeah
sleepers I don't even like you it'll be
hard to because you can't breathe I
snore like a [ __ ] and Nikki's a
deep sleeper thank God
Oh God a good combo you're lucky Wow for
me it's because I guess no matter what
position I sleep in I always end up with
my mouth wide open and I wake up with my
mouth feeling all drying oh my god I
feel like my lungs are just not very
well filtered because your nostrils
supposed to filter the air that you
breathe and I hate it so that's why I
would sleep with it I liked it you have
a strip on your lips
what's this concept that you don't know
I just don't get it how do you sleep in
your mouth restrictive geo get it you
literally don't feel it after you not
have oh hey alright Ryan I'm with Tim
it's weird it's just uh it's like a duct
tape on your face alright [ __ ] I'll try
it I guess
[Music]